هناك امل في الوصول الى حل تفاوضي للازمه
في النيجر لكن اذا نجح الانقلاب فسيكون
ذلك ماساه للمنطقه وستكون هناك انقلابات
اخرى
[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم باجاز من غرفه اخبار الجزيره
مرحبا بكم مع نهايه مهله ايكواس لقاده
الانقلاب في النيجر رئيس وزراء النيجر
يقول الجزيره ان هناك املا في التواصل لحل
تفوضي يجنب الولاده تدخلا عسكريا ويحذر من
موجه انقلابات في المنطقه اذا لم يوضع حد
لهذا الانقلاب في حين قالت باريس ان
وجودها في النيجر كان بطلب من السلطات
الشرعيه للمساعده في مكافحه الارهاب
في اعقاب هجمات على اهداف روسيه بالبحر
الاسود اوكرانيا تعلن تعرضها لاكثر من 70
هجوم روسيا بصواريخ ومسيرات بدورها اعلنت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه احباط هجوم بمسيره
استهدف موسكو وقالت انها قصفت قواعد جويه
غربيه اوكرانيا في حين توعد ميدفيديف
بهجمات تنهي اي امل في احياء اتفاق الحبوب
الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
غوتيريش يقول ان الطبول الحرب النوويه
بدات تقرع مره اخرى في رساله بعثها
بمناسبه احياء الذكرى الثامنه والسبعين
للهجوم النووي على مدينه هيروشيما
اليابانيه في نهايه الحرب العالميه
الثانيه حيث احيت المدينه الذكرى بمراسم
شارك فيها ممثلون عن اكثر من 100 بلد
ومنظمه دوريه
المنافسه تنتقل من العالم الافتراضي الى
الواقعي ترقب على المنصات لنزال القفص
المغلق بين مالكي شركه ميتا ومنصه اكس
تويتر سابقا بعد اعلان ايلون ماسك ان
نزاله سيتم في حلبه فيغاس اوكتاجون وانه
سيتم بثه على الهواء مباشره مؤكدا ان جميع
العائلات ستذهب الى الاعمال الخيريه
لقدماء المحاربين الى اللقاء